[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
football on jouait ce week-end le 5e
tour de la coupe de france le petit
poucet du département chambourcy
affronter le red star pensionnaire de
national malgré leurs efforts les
événements perdu 6 à 0 le résumé du
match dans ce magazine golf la golfeuse
2021 était organisée la semaine dernière
sur les greens du golf de saint jean les
les 16 meilleures équipes dames ont
participé à ces championnats de france
de première division reportage à suivre
voile louis burton a décidé de tester
son nouveau bateau bureau vallée 3 sur
la transat jacques vabre libinois
partira le 7 novembre avec son ami à
davy beaudart pour cette course
transatlantique en duo coup de
projecteur dont ceux à 7,8 sport
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
en football on jouait donc ce week-end
le 5e tour de la coupe de france le
petit poucet du département chambourcy
affronter le red star pensionnaire de
national malgré leurs efforts les
événements n'ont pas réussi à remporter
à la victoire face à une équipe qui
évolue huit divisions au dessus au
reportage
plus de 300 supporters autour du terrain
les sponsors sur les maillots le parfum
de la coupe de france flotter ce
dimanche 17 octobre sur chambourcy les
pensionnaires de 3e division de district
recevez le red star club de national
pour une rencontre de gala les espoirs
de qualification se sont envolés
rapidement bout de 20 secondes de jeu
les visiteurs ouvrent la marque 1 à 0
les huit divisions d'écart se font
ressentir les joueurs d'habib beye
accélère pour marquer deux puis trois
puis quatre puis cinq buts en première
période 5 à 0 à la mi temps je pense
qu'on était un peu stressé on s'est pris
un but au bout de 30 secondes de jeu
après on s'est un petit peu libéré mais
bon on a fait une première période
stressé j'ai envie de dire sur les dix
premières minutes on est quand on reste
quand même dans le match mais après
c'est la différence de niveau tout
simplement ça va beaucoup plus vite
c'est beaucoup plus propre il ya très
peu de déchets donc le résultat est
normal j'ai envie de dire en deuxième
période remobilisés à la pause par leur
entraîneur les yvelinois tiennent tête
aux pensionnaires de national il
encaisse seulement un but en 45 minutes
le match se termine sur le score de 6 à
0 pour les visiteurs c'est une belle
victoire tout important c'est ce que
l'on puisse avoir une fin est ici à
chambourcy j'avais échangé avec mehdi
avant le match l'entraîneur de
chambourcy donc voilà je pense que la
fête a eu lieu les gens sont contents
d'avoir vu un bon match de football
franchement belle fête super match
c'était vraiment quelque chose
d'incroyable d'extraordinaire on a tout
ce qui fait je pense malgré le score
malgré la défaite mais au-delà de ça
franchement c'était vraiment c'était
vraiment incroyable
malgré la défaite ce 5e tour restera le
plus beau parcours en coupe de france de
l'histoire du club de chambourcy une
belle épopée selon les spectateurs venus
assister au match parmi eux des
anciennes gloires du paris saint germain
cette équipe de chambourcy a montré des
belles valeurs les valeurs de la région
est
s'incliner contre le reste a requis une
équipe de national
je pense que c'est enrichissant une
expérience enrichissante qui pourrait
servir au club dans les prochaines
semaines dans le championnat de 3e
division de district les joueurs ont
désormais un objectif en tête une montée
en fin de saison
[Applaudissements]
on va continuer à parler de la coupe de
france de football avec bixente mérian
senti stéphane qui nous a rejoints sur
ce plateau pour soir bixente bon sens
mais qu'at elle alors avant de passer
aux autres résultats sportifs du week
end dans les yvelines où combien de
clubs illinois sont encore qualifiés en
coupe de france est ce qu'il en reste il
n'y en aura plus que 3 nickel de poissy
mais nous cherchons exactement il en
restera peut-être qu'un fera victoire
obtenue avec la manière en revanche
poissy d'abord l'a emporté 3 0 contre
sainte geneviève club de nationale 2
comme les pisciacais pour versailles et
chatou le tarif était de 4 buts à rien 4
0 sur la pelouse de cachan pour les
versaillais même score à domicile pour
château contrefoutre une fontenay sous
bois le week-end n'a pas souri en
revanche pour hardricourt trappe et
conflans tous défait sur le fil soit par
un but souad lors de la terrible épreuve
des penaltys ça joue aussi du côté des
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux
c'était du baseball il était en
déplacement à la rochelle oui une
victoire et une défaite pour les
baseballeurs unis montrent un dans ce
second tour des play dans ce week-end
c'était les deux premières rencontres
d'une série de cinq matchs face aux
boucaniers de la rochelle des matchs
pour décider de qui prendra la cinquième
place du classement la journée avait
bien commencé avec une première victoire
7-1 fait face aux boucaniers en revanche
le second match n'a pas souri aux
cougars une défaite au terme d'une
rencontre accrochée 6,5 la fin de la
série se jouera à montigny les 23 et 24
octobre pour trois matches décisifs on
passe maintenant aux biches et
décidément plaisir n'y arrive pas en
fédérale 2 une défaite 35 à 29 face à
courbevoie la troisième de suite pour
les plaisirs oies à la dixième position
ils tenteront de rebondir à domicile
dimanche prochain face à domont du
handball maintenant et on commence avec
les féminines de montigny le bretonneux
qui jouer la cinquième journée en
nationale 2 juillet une défaite de
justesse pour les inhumant ten en
territoire breton le score 28 à 27
contre tollé carantec des concurrents
directs pour la montée montigny
redescend à la cinquième place de cette
poule de nationale 2 au prochain match
elle se rendront nouvelle fois en
bretagne à lanester club qui se trouve à
égalité de points avec les vertes de
montigny 11 points donc au compteur côté
masculin en nationale 3 2 défaites pour
les yvelinois pourtant leader avant
cette 5e journée le club de houille
vésinet carrière s'est incliné à
domicile contre le paris fc leur
première défaite de la saison le score
19 à 23 même déception pour plaisir les
clés des fêtes 35 à 30 contre falaise le
hsbc est quatrième mais à égalité avec
les trois premiers plaisirs les clés est
à la septième position ce samedi en
basket trappe va mieux oui après sa
défaite la semaine dernière à levallois
trappe signe une nouvelle démonstration
dans la poule g de nationale 3 une
victoire 81 à 59 à la maison contre
marly le roi les trappistes sont
troisièmes à un point de la tête les
marly choix son dernier en revanche est
en grande difficulté dans cette division
avec que des défaites à leur actif dans
la poule f une cinquième défaite en cinq
matches aussi pour l'entente le
chesnay-versailles 70 à 58 sur le
parquet de tours merci à bixente pour
toutes ces précisions vous retrouve la
semaine à prochaine on va maintenant
parler des jeux olympiques 2000 24 après
le vélotour nationale le mois dernier
c'était au tour des longs cours
d'accueillir la délégation de la tournée
des drapeaux 2024 ce samedi 16 octobre
les trois étendard officiels ont été
présentés sur le stade guy boniface en
compagnie de thierry rey ancien champion
olympique de judo mois ci deux sportifs
élan courtois quentin lafargue champion
de france de cyclisme à amadou
championne du monde de boxe et cécile à
sabouraud athlètes handisport une
cérémonie pour célébrer l'esprit
olympique
cet événement était organisé à
l'occasion du premier élan courte
championne streel un parcours original
de 13 km qui passait par le futur site
olympique de la colline des longs cours
et s'achever par un passage à travers le
parc france miniature un reportage je
dois y canale et bixente mais rien senti
très bonne le parcours est très bien
dinan trahison
ce samedi 16 octobre plus de 600
courageux ont pris le départ du premier
élan courte championne ce trail un tracé
composé à 95% de chemins naturel belle
course belle montée qui cassent bien
mais pas très content et d'arrivée et la
bière fait du bien l'arrivée la faim
dans france nature et magnifique
magnifique conte signature franchement
c'était cd top en outre l'arrivée dans
le parc france miniature l'autre point
fort du parcours était sa dimension
olympique c'était l'originalité du
parcours qui était organisée aujourd'hui
c'était un de gravir la colline qui
demain en 2024 accueillera effectivement
l'épreuve vtt et c'était aussi
l'occasion de passer par france
miniature qui est un site touristique et
puissant il parce qu'on voit toute la
france sur les participants donc c'était
l'originalité du parcours les trois
passages à travers la célèbre colline
n'étaient pas les seules difficultés du
parcours même pour les vainqueurs du
jour c'était pas facile je pensais
qu'après la colline ça irait mieux est
en fait la montée pour rentrer jusqu'ici
a été finalement
difficile aussi la colline d'elancourt
c'est un coin où je m'entraîne souvent
on habitué à faire plusieurs dizaines de
monter donc là trois montées sébacées à
ce but mais c'était vraiment sympa comme
un gant bas record fort de ce succès
auprès des coureurs les l'encours
turbines serait il devrait être
reconduit à savoir si cela sera avant ou
après les jeux olympiques des travaux
devant commencer avant l'année prochaine
sur la colline
on voit maintenant parler à cyclisme le
parcours du tour de france 2022 a été
dévoilée la semaine dernière et grosse
surprise là à grande boucle ne
s'élancera pas des yvelines pour la 21e
et dernière étape mais des
hauts-de-seine une convention entre
l'organisateur et le à département des
yvelines a pourtant été signé en ce sens
en 2019 explications grosse déception
après rambouillet en 2019 mentent en
2020 et chatou en 2021 le tour de france
ne partira pas cette année des yvelines
il s'élancera de paris la défense arena
dans les hauts de seine la surprise est
d'autant plus grande que le département
avait signé une convention en 2019 avec
à etsaut l'organisateur du tour de
france cet accord devait faire des
yvelines le département départ de la 21e
étape jusqu'en 2023
selon nos confrères de l'écho
républicain citant le responsable presse
du tour de france cette option a été
validé par le conseil départemental des
yvelines en mettant en avant le
rapprochement yvelines et hauts de seine
le département de son côté ne s'est pas
exprimé maigre consolation si l'étape ne
partira pas des yvelines elle y passera
tout de même on devrait connaître les
détails du parcours en début d'année
prochaine en 2023 la dernière étape de
la grande boucle devrait partir du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
du golfe à présent la golfeurs se 2021
était organisée à la semaine dernière
sur les greens du golf de saint germain
en laye les meilleures équipes dames ont
participé à ces championnats de france
deux premières à division reportage
du suspense des larmes un temps
splendide tous les ingrédients étaient
réunis sur sept golfeurs 2021 saint jean
les ces championnats de france amateurs
de première division dames était
organisé du 13 au 17 octobre sur les
greens dessiné par l'architecte de golf
harry colts c'est la septième fois que
le site accueille l'épreuve le parcours
de saint germain s'adapte parfaitement
au jeu féminin il est un petit peu trop
court pour les grands joueurs
éventuellement de gaulle who
mais nous serons toujours favorable à
recevoir ce sept trophées ce trophée à
saint germain cette 87e édition a attiré
16 des meilleures équipes de france dont
des club yvelinois comme le racing club
de france saint jean d'angély ou encore
sans nom la bretèche c'est un événement
qu'on attend tout à chaque fois passée
une compétition par équipe et jouer pour
son club et avec son club c'est toujours
génial en plus le fait de jouer à saint
germain cette année et encore plus de
monde qui peut venir nous suivre donc
c'est assez particulier après cinq jours
de compétition c'est finalement sans nom
la bretèche qui remporte l'épreuve en
battant toulouse en finale
son dernier succès remontait à 2002 au
total le club yvelinois remporté la
gaule force pour la 19e fois de son
histoire c'est une surprise cette année
parce qu'on a quand même une équipe
relativement faible par rapport aux
autres et au final on a su s'accrocher
on a fait en adopter une bonne stratégie
qu'on respecte depuis le début de la
semaine le club remettra son titre en
jeu l'année prochaine avec un objectif
ramené une nouvelle fois la coupe à la
maison
on passe maintenant notre coup de
projecteur chaque semaine tv 60,18 vous
propose un zoom sur un club sportif ou
aux sportifs
aujourd'hui nous sommes allés à paris
pour rencontrer louis burton lors de la
présentation officielle de la transat
jacques vabre skipper évinois prendra le
départ le 7 novembre prochain depuis le
havre coup de projecteur
[Musique]
nous sommes à la maison de la radio à
paris aujourd'hui conférence de presse
pour la 15e édition de la transat
jacques vabre cette course en duo
reliera le havre à la martinique et un
ebe noah participera à la compétition
assez louis burton rambolitains
[Musique]
avant de rencontrer à louis burton je
suis est aux côtés de francis le goff le
directeur de course francis est ce que
tout est prêt à quelques semaines du
départ oui maintenant tout est
pratiquement prêt il ya encore quelques
qualification à faire parce qu'avant de
pouvoir concourir à la transat jacques
vabre faut que le duo se qualifier
puisse faire 1000 milles nautiques
ensemble avec le bateau qui va courir
donc il ya encore quelques quelques
équipages qui manque cette qualification
mais ça ne saurait tarder et puis au
havre comme en martinique
les infrastructures sont prêtes les
parcours ont été dévoilées donc voilà
c'est avec impatience maintenant qu'on
attend l'arrivée des bateaux au havre le
28 à 15h dernier carat et puis le fameux
grand départ 13 heures 30 le dimanche 7
novembre justement vous le disiez la
martinique cette année pourquoi c était
une évidence tellement ils ont montré de
motivation c'est une candidature
spontanée
poussé par un certain nombre de skippers
et puis damien de longueville qui
représente le groupe gbh mais aussi le
le syndicat de tourisme de martinique
qui ont vraiment montré énormément de
motivation pour nous accueillir et il
nous appartenait alors de garder les les
traceurs les marqueurs de cette transat
jacques vabre c'est pour ça que vous
avez trois banques grand parcours
différents et qu'est ce que ça change
pour vous en tant que directeur de
course
au final ça change rien du tout
voilà on n'aura pas à parler portugais
c'est vraiment ça c'est ça qui change
parce que pour le reste les marqueurs
sont là et on a la même attention aux
marins qu'on aille à salvador de bahia
où en martinique 15e édition de la
transat jacques vabre tout simplement
est ce que vous sentez que l'événement
monte en puissance d'année en année
peut-être qu'il ya plus d'engouement
peut-être autour de cet événement oui
elle a 15 ans maintenant elle est bien
inscrite voilà dans le calendrier des
courses au large cette nouvelle
direction a su aussi insufflé beaucoup
de projets autour de la transat qui à
mon sens cela rend encore plus
attractive évidemment il ya le plateau
sportif il ya les bateaux il ya le
parcours mais il ya tout ce qu'elle
engage aux côtés du point de vue
environnemental sociétal
d'inclusion j'en veux pour preuve cette
initiative fabuleuse de cap pour elle et
d'offrir la possibilité à de jeunes
femmes de courir cette transat jacques
vabre voilà c'est ça aussi qui l'amène
aujourd'hui à ce niveau on a 80 bateaux
au départ à cette année un record c'est
un record absolu ces 80 bateaux c'est
aussi 160 marins dans kid dont il faut
se se préoccuper voilà avec quatre
belles classe
j'imagine que les premiers jours de
course vont être très très intenses tel
le vent le plateau est élevé en tant que
directeur de course est ce que vous avez
peut-être des des astuces je ne sais pas
pour remporter la victoire non j'en ai
aucune et je m'interdis bien d'en avoir
en tous les cas ce que je sais c'est que
il faudra partir très vite pour déjouer
les pièges de la manche et puis après ce
jour pareil à l'aspect sportif mais il
faut pas oublier que en temps on évolue
dans un milieu maritime et qu'à un
moment donné la prise de conscience du
du marin au regard de la météo et des
conditions font aussi la différence
savoir passer d'un mode très performant
ça un mode plutôt de marins de
gestionnaires de la situation c'est
sûrement une des clés pour remporter la
transat jacques vabre chez 78 on suit un
marin en particulier un skipper en
particulier c'est louis burton est ce
qui pourrait soulever cette coupe dans
quelques semaines bah oui au regard de
ce qu'il a produit au vendée globe
notamment il a aujourd'hui un bateau
super puissant très performant
et puis on connaît on connaît le marin
voilà il est c'est quelqu'un qui est
très engagée dans ces courses et il fait
évidemment partie des favoris c'est sa
sixième édition sur ce tournage jacques
vabre est ce que l'expérience va peut
être jouer en sa faveur oui alors là par
contre ya beaucoup de gens expérimentés
c'est plutôt la la la la forme actuelle
du marin sa manière d'aborder la course
qui peut plus faire la différence que
l'expérience en elle-même parce que ça
pour le coup beaucoup d'entre eux l'ont
merci à francis le goff et on va tout de
suite rencontré à louis burton
[Musique]
louis burton est enfin avec hawtai
bonjour louis bonjour à tous on est ravi
de vous avoir une nouvelle fois sur tv
78 alors avant de parler de cette
transat jacques vabre on va regarder
tout de suite ce reportage qui parle de
ta carrière louis à 36 ans louis burton
a connu une carrière riche navigue entre
les échecs et les succès en 2010 le
skipper de rambouillet participe à sa
première route du rhum sur bureau vallée
avant de tenter l'année suivante une
transat jacques vabre avec son frère
nelson où il termine septième c'est en
2012 qu'il participe à son premier
vendée globe pour sa première expérience
il percute un chalutier en mer quelques
jours après le départ on ne peut pas
dire qu'on pense terminer la course
parce que c'est c'est il ya une
dimension aventure donc l'entreprise
dont la fin n'est pas certaine sur le
vendée globe li a à peu près 50 % de la
flotte qui abandonnent chaque édition
c'est un peu la statistique après des
transats jacques vabre et des routes du
rhum prometteuse avec des top 5 en 2016
louis burton repart pour un deuxième
vendée globe ces aléas et ces moments
uniques une balade une bonne
sans rire quoi
aussi proche
cette fois ci le skipper a appris de ses
erreurs il arrive en 7e position sables
d'olonne arriver aux sables oui en 87
jours
à 7e place avec ce bateau d'une dizaine
d'années c'est vraiment dans la partie
haute des objectifs en 2020 louis burton
débute son troisième vendée globe à bord
de bureau vallée après quelques frayeurs
sur la première partie de course il
répare son bateau sur l'île macquarie au
sud de l'australie ce système 3 pour en
tête demain pour remplacer luca j'espère
que vous apprécierez aussi du plus bas
on voit
donc maintenant
on va descendre sans se casser la figure
on va renvoyer la jv et on va lui même
pour entrer au ca après une magnifique
remontée louis burton termine 3e du
vendée globe 2020 après 81 jours de
course c'est grande joie pour moi une
grande satisfaction et puis
personnellement une grande fierté ce
qu'il a fallu aller la chercher du début
à la fin cette place
aujourd'hui le skipper vise encore plus
haut pour remporter sa première victoire
sur le vendée globe en 2024 les viennois
partir avec un nouveau bateau plus
performants dernière génération baptisé
bureau vallée 3
alors louis une carrière très riche on
l'a vu dans le reportage merci c'est
vrai que ça a démarré en 2010 et ça
s'est enchaîné sont vraiment qu'il y ait
de pause depuis donc ça fait pas mal de
transat ça fait une troisième vendée
globe qui s'est terminée cette année et
puis bah toutes les courses d'avant
saison donc mine de rien ça fait un
paquet d'un paquet 2001 paquet d'avants
tueur en mer depuis depuis ces vingt
dernières années est-ce que tu as un
soulignant en particulier qui quittent
revient à l'esprit eh ben c'est passé
plusieurs éléments marquants mais les
premières premiers bords sur l'eau gamin
ensuite
le perfectionnement régate à saint
quentin en yvelines et puis tous acquis
ensuite arrive sur une première route du
rhum en 2010 et puis et puis le vendée
globe sur un podium là cette année en
2021 c'est ces voix-là plein d'étapes
comme sa forte dans ma vie oui justement
cette troisième place sur ce vendée
globe est ce que c'est un peu
l'apothéose pour l'instant ou pas encore
c'est sûr que c'est c'est vraiment de
notre un peu nos jeux olympiques anosy
et c'est une des épreuves les plus
difficiles au monde en termes de course
au large est monté sur le podium c'est
mon plus beau résultat aujourd'hui est
donc voilà j'en suis très fière et j'en
suis fier pour toute l'équipe et puis ça
a donné aussi l'opportunité de partir
sur un cycle de cinq ans un nouveau
cycle de cinq ans avec mes partenaires
alors la transat jacques vabre s'est pas
forcément une course facile vous êtes en
duo est-ce que ce que tu as vécu lors du
vendée globe va te servir sur cette
transat jacques vabre attend la lui a
déjà le fait de partir sur une jacques
vabre après un vendée globe il ya
plusieurs éléments qui sont intéressants
1 on a du coup l'impression qu'une le
format transat va être très court et
donc va passer très vite puisque la
dernière fois qu'on était en mer c'était
pour trois mois et puis on est en double
donc on peut attaquer comme on le fait
quand on est tout seul sur un vendée et
en même temps se reposer donc donc oui
l'expérience du vendée globe va servir
pour ça et puis c'est une épreuve qui
est sur le même parcours que le début du
vendée globe donc on a encore en tête
voilà tout ce début de parcours c'était
l'alizé le passage du pot-au-noir qu'on
va devoir passer deux fois cette année
du coup c'est un sprint contrairement en
vendée globe comment ça se gère
justement est-ce qu'il faut être plus
rapide peut-être dès le début qu'est-ce
qu'ils commencent à agir tout simplement
eh ben ça se gère en étant au taquet du
début à la fin c'est sur quel passage en
manche où
il faut faire attention il ya beaucoup
de monde on passe le long de codes du
courant on passe à côté des rails de
cargos etc et puis ensuite on arrive
dans le golfe de gascogne c'est la
période des premières dépression
hivernale à ce moment là donc on sait
qu'on a en général deux ou trois
passages de front ou faut faire
attention parce qu'on peut vraiment
exploser nos bateaux et puis ensuite
derrière en théorie si l'analyse est
assez bien d'installer sa déroule
jusqu'au poteau noir quels sont ses
objectifs justement sur cette course on
a entendu tout à l'heure lors de la
présentation peut être un podium est ce
que ça sera le cas on vise on vise un
top 5 avec avec des vies on a le bateau
pour cette année on aura quand même pu
naviguer pas mal avec on a nos sponsors
et dont le bureau vallée en tête qui
nous permettent de faire un nouveau jeu
de voiles qui nous permettent de
vraiment préparé notre bateau donc on
vise un top 5 et on rêve on rêve
secrètement de monter sur le podium mais
justement ce bureau vallée 3 ce nouveau
bateau que tu as eue récemment comment
comment tu l'as présente justement tu as
déjà fait quelques courses récemment
est-ce qu'il est bien tout simplement
parce qu'ils répondent à des attentes
oui le nouveau bureau vallée très rapide
il est très aérien aussi avec une carène
qui est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
planantes que l'ancien bateau
et donc on va plus vite on
on a des folles qui sont beaucoup plus
grand donc on a un avant très spatule et
ça nous permet de tenir des vitesses
moyennes plus élevé donc voilà il ya ça
se règle pas de la même manière mais il
ya un potentiel qui est vraiment
supérieure est ce que tu penses que tu
seras prêt dès cette transat jacques
vabre avec ce bateau il faudra encore un
petit peu de temps à ce qu'on sait que
ton objectif c'est le prochain vendée
globe forcément oui il faut un peu plus
de temps là c'est sûr qu'on va être
encore en phase de découverte de ce
nouveau bureau vallée donc il va falloir
falloir qu'on se concentre énormément on
a en face de nous des gens qui qui sont
très performants qu'ils connaissent par
coeur leur machine donc donc voilà il va
falloir qu'on il va falloir qu'on donne
beaucoup avec des vis pour arriver à
concurrencer alors tu as maintenant
beaucoup d'expérience sur la transat
jacques vabre je crois que c'est à
sixième participation si je me trompe
pas sixième participation tu es parti
avec ton frère tu es parti avec ta femme
lasse avec un ami on peut le dire avec
qui tu es déjà partis en 2019 ouais on
est déjà parti ensemble avec des vues en
2019 c'est un ami ça c'est sûr depuis
très longtemps mais c'est aussi un grand
champion puisqu'il a il a gagné
énormément énormément de courses dans
toute sa carrière et puis c'est
quelqu'un qui a une grande compétence
dans le développement technique des
bateaux et et est donc on est assez
complémentaires sur ces aspects là et ça
se passe très bien sur l'eau on se
complète avant la course et sur l'eau on
fait tout ensemble on se on a pas besoin
de se parler très longtemps pour se
comprendre donc donc voila et on a tous
les deux envie d'aller très vite et
tirer le meilleur profit de nouveau
bureau vallée
alors davy beaudart nous à nous a
rejoint alors des vies super cette
course à deux avec louis burton c'est ce
que ce que tu ressens tout simplement
super j'irai plus tôt
excitant génial en fait super c'est
encore un petit peu léger mais moi j'ai
beaucoup d'excitation et d'envié de
partir sur cette course déjà parce que
avec lui ça marche super et le bateau le
bateau est génial en fait un super
bateau nouvelle génération beaucoup de
potentiel et
il ya de très belles choses à faire et
que cet engin de guerre dont vous avez
fait quelques courses ensemble avec
récemment avec louis comment comment ça
se travaille justement cette transat
jacques vabre à 2 eh bien
c'est en fait c'est même plus qu'à deux
c'est tout un team qui travaillent au
quotidien pour le bateau nous on est la
partie émergée de l'iceberg
on navigue en mai
le bateau c'est sont des formule 1 donc
il ya un travail énorme en amont est
fait pour fiabiliser pour préparer pour
performer
nous nous on va essayer de conduire la
machine du mieux possible louis m'a dit
à quelques instants que vous étiez
complémentaires est ce que c'est le cas
je passerai 10 anni avant la cause mais
ce que c'est le cas
c'est vrai moi je moi je fais plus à
manger que lui c'est vrai
maintenant on est complémentaires moi je
suis assez technique de ma formation de
mon passé
louis
oui il ya une bonne gestion la météo la
stratégie de course après on touche tous
les deux à tous les tous les domaines on
sent vraiment la grande force c'est
qu'on s'entend vraiment très bien
et qu'on prend beaucoup de plaisir sur
le louis burton partira le 7 novembre
prochain depuis le port du havre le
départ sera donné à 13h30 direction à la
martinique
on termine par un rendez vous football
le psg qui s'entraînait ici à dans les
yvelines va affronter l'olympique de
marseille ce dimanche soir au vélodrome
un match est qu une saveur particulière
puisque les deux équipes sont sur le
podium de ligue 1 on écoute juan
bernales le joueur du paris saint
germain grégory canale et nicolas landry
l'ont interviewé à la sortie du parc des
princes ce vendredi soir
avant le match contre marseille nous
avons un match très important contre
lexique en ligue des champions nous
serons à la maison et nous devons
obtenir les trois points pour continuer
à être les leaders de notre groupe en
champion's league et puis après nous
verrons pour marseille et je crois que
l'équipe est préparée on aura nos
internationaux qui pour certains sont
rentrés aujourd'hui de leur match en
amérique du sud dès dimanche nous allons
nous préparer pour toute la semaine qui
est une semaine très importante avec des
matches importants pour nous
c'est la fin de cette émission très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]